grab your Boomstick and S smart discount
card this is my boom stick the latest
iteration of the Evil Dead universe is
here and I'm glad to say it's
we're gonna take a deep dive into the
new film it's Easter eggs and even Bruce
Campbell's cameo in the film yes Bruce
does have a cameo and it's really easy
to miss but I'll be pointing it out as
we go along so give me some sugar baby
and make sure to like And subscribe
because this is one hell of a trip the
movie actually starts one day after the
main events of the film this is Teresa a
young woman peer pressured into coming
to her cousin's stupid boyfriend's Cabin
in the Woods already you can make out
this cabin which still maintains the
feel of evil dead but you know they've
changed it up a little bit it's now a
triangle inside is an old clock and
homage the clock found in Evil Dead one
and two but it's by the lake where we
meet Caleb and his drone we'll actually
see a POV shot of it traveling through
the forest which mimics the iconic POV
demon shots found in the original evil
Deads Teresa can't stand her cousin's
boyfriend Caleb don't worry Teresa he
won't be here long so she makes her way
back into the cabin to check on her
cousin who's been feeling a bit under
the weather now if I came into the cabin
and my cousin looked like this I'd
definitely be calling 9-1-1 turns out
Jessica has been possessed and proceeds
to pull the scalp right off Teresa's
head and when this happened in the
theater everyone audibly gasped it was
pretty [__] awesome Teresa manages to
escape and rushes to Caleb but possessed
Jessica isn't too far behind she grabs
Caleb's drone and uses its blade to cut
up her own face before descending into
the water and then levitating from the
lake this was honestly one of the better
openings of a horror movie I've seen in
a long time rewind one day earlier were
the main events of our story take place
this is Beth our protagonist a guitar
tech who spent the last few years
focused on becoming the best at her job
which has also meant putting aside her
family especially her sister Ellie who
is going through a bad breakup Beth
wasn't there for Ellie in her time of
need and now that Beth needs her it's
created a bit of Rift between the two
Beth Scott and herself pregnant and
isn't sure what to do about the baby at
family dinner we meet Ellie's three
children Danny Bridget and Cassie Cassie
here is the youngest of the bunch who
enjoys spending her free time chopping
the heads off dolls she's actually
making her own doll named Stephanie Yes
you heard me right Stephanie is a doll
whose head is lovingly spiked onto his
staff an item which will come in handy
later on the kids are charged with
picking up pizza and there's a fun
Easter egg here with the name of the
pizza joint being henrietta's Pizza the
name of the first person to be possessed
by the kandarian demon in Evil Dead 2.
it's on their way back that an
earthquake opens a pothole beneath their
Apartments parking garage you see this
old apartment building was built on an
old bank and the Quake has opened a path
to the bank's hidden vault and Dany
being The Adventurous young man that he
is takes it upon himself to investigate
inside the Vault are all sorts of
religious paraphernalia including
crosses hung from the ceiling and Medals
of Saint Benedict the medal of Saint
Benedict is often seen at the center of
a crucifix behind the head of Christ to
ward off evil spirits so so it seems
whoever controlled this Vault was quite
rich and Powerful Dany reaches in to
find a book covered in insects revealing
the Necronomicon The Book of the Dead
found by archaeologist Raymond Noby in
Evil Dead 2. it has somehow made its way
to this Vault now I should mention there
are different versions of this book in
Army of Darkness we actually see three
copies of it but it's never explained
whether the one in Evil Dead rise is the
same as the other films there's actually
a theory out there that one of the books
belongs to the original trilogy one to
the 2013 Evil Dead remake directed by
fetty Alvarez and the last one to Evil
Dead rise so Dany grabs the book along
with three mysterious vinyls early on in
the film we see how Dany is an aspiring
DJ which will later tie into him being
able to play these records although not
visible in the trailers behind Dany is a
large poster for fake chimp the term
used to describe as stand-in for an
actor unavailable to perform their role
something Sam Raimi and brother Ted had
to do multiple times during the filming
of the evil Dead one of the things this
film does well are its setups and
payoffs for example there's a scene
where Cassie hides a pair of scissors
under the couch and later on in the
movie those scissors will be used to
fight off Ellie or how Beth is a guitar
tech a skill which will allow her to
create a battery to play the speakers
when the electricity later shuts off but
I'm digressing the first vinyl we hear
the voice of priest Marcus Littleton in
the year 1923 and yes that's Bruce
Campbell's Cameo who voices the priest
he's come to a conclave and wants to use
the Necronomicon to learn from it but
the other priest disavow him forcing him
and two other priests to learn the
book's secrets on their own vinyl 2 is
the reciting of the Demonic Words which
ultimately compel a demonic Spirit to
descend upon their apartment now I
should preface that this building is
really old and set to be demolished next
month which allows for some unique plot
points later on with this demon on its
way it possesses its first victim Ellie
who is on her way to do some laundry
when her body is entangled in elevate
later wires similar to the Demonic vines
that grab victims in Evil Dead 1 and 2.
the now possess definitely decides it's
time to make some delicious breakfast
throwing eggs into a pan like the first
time I tried to make breakfast in bed
for my mom and even creepier she tells
them she wants to slide into their
bodies so they can be a happy family
forever before proceeding to vomit
profusely and passing out they'll put
her in a bathtub to cool down but she's
so hot it ends up boiling the water her
body shoots out levitating onto the
ceiling mommy's like the maggots down
she then proceeds to collapse and die
but with everything Evil Dead we know
that won't be for long a few moments
later as Beth talks to her dead sister
about everything she's sorry for Ellie
miraculously wakes up but this time
she's on a demonic Killing Spree she'll
use a Shard of glass to stab Beth
through the hand then attacks Bridget
with a tattoo pen this is already
turning out slightly better than one of
my family gatherings unfortunately
Bridget is infected here but they're
able to push Ellie out into the hallway
where she makes quick work of their
neighbors including Mr Fonda who owns a
shotgun and a wood chipper down in the
parking garage both of which will come
into play later on there's even this fun
homage to Evil Dead 2 where one of the
neighbor's eyes gets torn out and popped
into another person's mouth Cassie looks
through the peephole as her mother tries
to convince her to open the door open up
now I don't know about you guys but
there's no way in hell I'm opening that
door nothing a big old hug and kiss from
you won't fix okay maybe foreign
luckily the others are able to push
their demon mom back and regroup for a
new plan if the necronomicons summon
this evil entity maybe it can also stop
it so Dany shows his aunt the book and
vinyls in the hopes they can find a
solution at the same time Bridget's
decided it's a great time for a glass of
chardonnay oh God she attacks her aunt
using a cheese grater to slice off part
of her leg I hate when that happens but
Beth's able to light her on fire and now
we're down to three survivors Beth
listens to that final vinyl all alone
just in case it stirs any more demons
the hope is that it may hold a clue to
stop them but instead it's a warning
there is no stopping it unfortunately
during this time Elias crept into the
air duct and found her way inside Dany
comes to Beth's aid but is killed in the
process and soon he'll become a demon
too but it's actually Cassie who saves
the day when while hiding under the
couch tosses Beth some scissors which
best stabs in Ellie's face allowing the
two of them to escape into the hallway
now you you may have been wondering why
haven't they been able to escape thus
far one the elevator is out of order and
two the earthquake caused the staircase
to crumble apart just the worst their
cell phones don't work and they can't
yell outside because they're too high up
and it's pouring rain which drowns out
the sound so Beth and Cassie make their
escape to the dimly lit Hall to try to
get their way to the emergency stairwell
their neighbor's corpses have yet to be
possessed by the Demonic entity
unfortunately the door leading to this
fire escape has been heavily locked and
Beth will need some heavy duty Firepower
if they're going to get past it luckily
their neighbor Mr Fonda still has his
shotgun on him a trademark Evil Dead
weapon but Beth ends up using it to fend
off Ellie as she re-emerges from the
apartment with no time left in a
possessed of Bridget and Danny coming to
their mother's Aid Beth and Cassie lock
themselves in the elevator this is when
Ellie fuses with Bridget and Danny into
one fugly monstrosity with multiple
appendages it's kind of similar to the
image found in the Book of the Dead and
aligns with demon Ellie's idea that now
they can be one happy family by
literally being bound together Cassie
and Beth have no other choice but to
lock themselves in the broken elevator
which slowly starts to fill with blood
until it reaches its weight limit and
don't ask me how this works but it
crashes 14 stories and they survive the
doors opening like in The Shining but
damn does it look cool Beth and Cassie
open the parking garage gate but Cassie
is pulled at the last second separating
her from Beth now Beth must force her
way back into the garage and save her
niece culminating in a brutal finale
where she almost gets sucked into the
back of a wood chipper luckily Mr
Fonda's truck has a handy dandy chainsaw
a staple of the Evil Dead series Beth
picks it up and guts the demon pushing
it further and further into the wood
chipper showering the entire parking
garage in blood Beth has saved the day
and throughout her journey has learned
the importance of family although never
stated it's highly likely she'll keep
that baby now this is where we track
back to the events at the beginning of
the film home Jessica the possessed
woman lives in the same apartment
building as Beth and her family only
nine floors down on floor five so she
probably didn't hear any of the crazy
events that went on she makes her way
down to the parking lot where the camera
Zooms in in the traditional Evil Dead
POV so it can be assumed that Jessica
was possessed by this entity drove
herself to that Cottage and would later
become this thing that ascends from the
lake it's a fun way to Circle back to
the beginning and leave the room open
for future sequels there's also the
question of the Necronomicon and vinyls
themselves which are still upstairs what
will happen to them I really think Evil
Dead rise was the shot in the heart this
franchise needed and if they could
create more stories like this I'll
definitely be along for the ride but
what did you think of Evil Dead rise I
want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below thanks for watching and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember Shop Smart Shop
S Mart
foreign